how are you feeling today i
am feeling exhausted i'm feeling um
overwhelmed a little bit but super
excited there's like a slew of emotions
that are going on inside of me and um
but i'm just happy to be here
why are you here and not moose what
happened
oh my gosh
honestly um
i think one of my downfalls in my
campaigning was that i didn't do enough
of it
um i was a little too nice
and but that's just the person that i am
i was never going to throw moose under
the bus
um with with my campaigning and i think
that that's one of the reasons that
landed me on the block and out of the
house essentially
were you shocked when you heard the vote
i thought it was 5'4 like it was so
close
it was so close just to think that my
entire game was in helena's hands
essentially was
the scariest feeling in the world
i tried to have a conversation with her
right before
the vote and i pleaded my case i damn
near begged
um
but
she seemed very dead set on you know
taking the information that jess had
given to her and just
going with that it was very unfortunate
and just so sad i couldn't believe that
i didn't even get a chance to play in
the veto and being backdoored is
the worst feeling in the world
yeah it must feel defeating because you
can't do anything you just have to live
with that moment
with that moment
and
just i was i'm just speechless now
because you know i
saw that jess was immediately evicted
after me and i'm like why did you do
this i could have still been in there
like come on
who do you think will be next to leave
i think that
i hope that marty doesn't win
um hoh i really really hope that doesn't
happen because if he does he's going to
be taking shots at the squad and
if that's the case i think that maybe
uh her mom
will be one of those one of those
targets because hermann is is
on this on the track to win this game
and i think that he might be the next
winner if marty wins
that's fair that's fair i was going to
ask you who do you think is going to win
but you just answered it right there
absolutely marty is somebody that the
the house guests need to get out like
yesterday because he is mentally strong
he is physically strong he has a great
story behind him his family he's from a
small town like there's a lot going for
him to win this game so they need to get
him out
would you do anything differently if you
had the chance to do it all over again
it's hard to
um
think about that and and go down that
rabbit hole i want to say that overall i
have no regrets i think the one thing
that i would have tweaked a little bit
is just to have campaigns a little
harder i think that was essentially my
downfall i was too nice and i easily
took the pawn idea um you know just did
say that i was more level headed and i
would take it better than betty or
summer or could she didn't want that
smoke this summer that's for sure um
sorry they didn't want that smo that
smoke with summer for sure um but i
think that if i could tweak anything it
would be to campaign a little bit harder
and what do you think of summer's game
right now
i think summer's doing her thing her
spice her just her attitude on life the
way that she is in with everybody
everybody loves summer she's just a ball
of energy and i think she's doing a
great job right now she will absolutely
pull out a win when she needs to um
she's kind of been
uh flying under the radar in like the
physical aspect and and purposely not
winning competitions just to rely on her
social game which has worked great for
her so far so i think that she's playing
an amazing game and i know
for damn sure that she's going to pull
out those wins when it's absolutely
necessary
and my last question for you is what
message do you want to leave with your
fans because you have a lot of fans out
there supporting you
first of all i can't even wrap my mind
around having fans like
wow i never thought in a million years
that i would have fans that love me to
be honest i went into the house with the
goal of being authentic and being myself
and just showcasing how much of a happy
bubbly person that i am this is exactly
who i am in real life and all my friends
and family can attest to that i just
wanted to show you know the canada and
all of anyone who's watching that i
truly believe in you getting through any
type of obstacle in your life um being a
single mother it has not been easy um
at all but
look i ended up on big brother canada
like who would have thunk it right so um
to all of my amazing fans i love you all
thank you for supporting me and you i
hope that i get another chance to be on
another platform so that you can see me
on your tvs again soon
maybe the challenge we gotta get you on
the chat
let's manifest that
into the universe if i can get on the
challenge challenge gods just take me
now
you